-Guys, we have
exactly three shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ Three days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an extraordinary
Christmas sweater
from our
Countdown to Christmas cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Now, since there are
three shows left,
let's open door number three.
Where's three? Oh, here.
When -- Whenever you're ready.
Go for it.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait. Wow, wow. Yeah.
Let's see it.
Oh. Wow.
Oh, that is -- That is...
That is something.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
Maybe that's --
Look at this thing. Ooh, yeah.
That's like...
Show the back to them?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is space age.
Wow. Fantastic.
Now, let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll
please?
[ Drum roll ]
242!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi!
Welcome! Hi! Welcome!
Come on over!
Aw, look at you.
Hello. What is your name?
-Karina.
-Karina, where are you from?
-Jersey.
-Yeah! Jersey!
Alright, good.
Karina from Jersey.
You already look like
you're in the holiday spirit.
I love the -- But I think that
this will just kind of go
with everything.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
-No one -- You won't stand out
in Jersey wearing this.
-I know. I'm gonna
go to dinner in this.
-You should.
Would you like to try it on?
-Can I?
-Yes, please.
I think we'd love to see it.
This is gonna be amazing.
I think it's gorgeous.
There...
♪♪
Yeah. It's easy to get on.
[ Laughter ]
Look at this.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you joking me?
Yo. Karina, look at you.
You're...
That looks like
a super model on our show.
It's unbelievable.
Gorgeous.
Thank you so much for
being here! I appreciate it.
Another round of applause
for our winner.
You can leave if you want.
You can stay.
Whatever you feel like doing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Round of applause
for our winner right there.
Stick around!
We've got more "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
♪♪